[Music]
okay everybody i'm really excited today
because i am joined by two people
olivia welch aka heather and ray
nicholson aka ray
in the new amazon prime video series
panic how you guys doing today
good how are you i'm doing good i'm
excited
i rarely do interviews with two people
but i wanted to do this one with you
guys together
i'm so excited to talk to you guys so
with this
show coming out i feel like there's
gonna be a lot of comparisons to the
hunger games
can you kind of give me what do you
think separates panic from the hunger
games or someone was like oh it's gonna
be too similar
what's what's the edge here well i think
the interesting thing about this show is
that it kind of takes that really crazy
high-stakes life or death game and it
puts it in this sort of
not low stakes but like this really
small town um
and like obviously in high school like
all these things going on in high school
being 18 having an existential crisis
like in a girl like you know it puts all
those things together um
so it kind of gives it a new flavor for
sure
and it's just it's not as um it's not
like dystopian in any way and it takes
place
in modern day in like real society and
so
i i it'll be fun because i think there
are things that people will be like oh
yeah like i
i i have an instagram you know
modern teenage years play into the show
no yeah that those are both great
answers and it's interesting too you
guys play both
some big characters were these the parts
you always read for were you always
going to be heather and ray or was there
someone else
you might have actually been cast as i
think i only ever read for heather
i believe yeah i only ever read for
heather did you ever read for anyone
else
no i only read for rey and um
i was actually like you know we had
several callbacks and for the last
callback
you know my manager's like ray you know
you're real close like you know make
sure you got
i was on the way to the audition and my
phone ran out of battery and i had no
idea where the audition was so i was
really late
trying to charge my phone like in this
random place across the street was like
freaking out
and uh and i
i just went in there and i was like ray
would not apologize so i didn't
apologize and i just did the thing and i
ended up
it was fun yeah yeah i love that so i
got in like a very someone clipped my
car on my way to my audition
and then i was like heather would
apologize so i walked it i was like i'm
so sorry
okay that's that's amazing
so that's interesting too i have a
question for you olivia so
i was going down your imdb page and deep
down i found
a fact that says you play french horn
can you confirm this
and he still whip it out to blow off
some steam from time to time um
i do play french porn i haven't since i
was
young like eight okay grade but i
probably could still do it i have a
mouthpiece still and i can still like
which is the most important part of
rendering um hell yeah
i could probably you know practice up
and and get back into it
i love it uh ray is there a thrill
playing a character who is mostly a jerk
to people do you get a thrill out of
that
um i mean absolutely uh absolutely
you know being someone's got to be the
jerk you know um
i feel like the jerk makes the world go
around no i don't know
it's pretty fun you know it's fun like
it's kind of a
weird feeling for sure um but
you know i enjoyed it i enjoyed the hell
out of it no i love the honesty
and uh it's interesting so you guys now
being
two leads now in this amazon prime
series are you
looking forward to the attention that
brings or is it kind of scary for you
guys
i'm scared i'm a little scared just
because i
am pretty shy in real life i feel like
or when it comes to
interacting with like yeah like i'm just
uh i'm i'm pretty private and i'm a
little shy so i'm like oh it'll be
interesting but i'm excited to um you
know just get to like work with
different people from this that's always
i think your hope is an actor is that
a job parlays into another job um so i'm
excited for those things and to have
you know those opportunities and
conversations with people that's what
i'm like really looking forward to
you know i'm i'm i'm excited and nervous
you know i'm mostly nervous to be honest
with you
you know um at the end of the day it's
like you know you have to remember who
you are
you know and you know you're i'm i'm
really lucky that i have
great friends great family and you know
at the end of the day it's like i i have
a bunch of other actor buddies that call
me they're like oh my god you know and
then you just realize
i don't care what you do like you're my
you're my guy you know so
yeah no that's that's great and i think
that's like
just inspiring too because i feel like
there's so many shows coming out but
you see how much of a spotlight it puts
you in being on a big streaming service
and i think people are going to be
excited to learn about you guys not just
the characters you play but
you as people so that's really cool i
also have to ask too because it's kind
of tripped me out a bit are you guys in
the same room because you both have that
same gray background are you sitting
next to each other
were uh yeah we we got a similar gray
cloth
in the mail okay okay it looks like from
my of you guys are connected right now
but okay
hey hey that would be i mean i i will
say though
olivia's gray cloth is way nicer looking
mine has
all these creases
yeah she got the she got the better one
yeah maybe she like did a little ironing
before i don't know
i swear i swear just
spit on it yeah anyway my last question
for you guys
is is there anything in your life either
you experienced that
was anywhere close to like the game of
panic like anything in school
any kind of competition
i don't know i grew up in texas i think
that's why
i love to panic as i yeah i'm from i'm
from texas so
going back i was like going back to my
roots like we are gonna go
back to texas and um so that was fun and
it made me i feel like
when i left texas i was like i'm getting
out of here but going back i was like oh
this is like nice to be back home and
i have a newfound love for this for the
state
love it what about you or anything uh i
mean
like i'm sure looking back there's a ton
of stuff and i'm like
so stupid like why yeah why did you do
that uh
one of the things i guess i actually
actually ran with the bulls before
um
yeah that was completely psychotic and
we got there late
we were you know of course drunk and
like
which is like the most dangerous place
we were with like all these crazy
suicidal spaniards it was really fun but
i love it
very very bad
no that's awesome guys thank you so much
for joining me
everyone please make sure to watch panic
on amazon prime video may 28th
and to quote olivia on instagram with a
great handle welch welch welch welch
this show has everything cowboys mullets
ghosts stunts house parties llamas
friendship
cliff jumping dr pepper big cats denim
cutoff stunts twists and turns
i'll use her quote so make sure you
heard it from her watch it
thank you guys for joining me and i hope
to talk to you guys again in the future
thank you so much youtube
get it thank you that's an incredible
quote olivia
thank you so much i worked very hard on
that instagram caption really strong
i just sat there and was like what is in
this show and then i listed off
everything i could remember
quite a bit it's quite a crazy show
you're even leaving out some stuff which
is pretty good i know
that's why i stole it right there yeah
that makes me feel so
appreciated deep down you don't even